quant à une longueur genre livre c'est
le sexe tous les murs aulas a apporté
que c'est plus le cadeau de baraka s'est
dit qu'est ce que tu m'as offert ben
vous venez ouvrir un bon soir il ya déjà
des amours d'abord en faire un cadeau se
faire par la prod nous par vous alors
c'est personnel ah d'accord à ce que
c'était et c'est moi qui ai payé ça
c'est personnel
et c'est un beau cadeau
attendez vous aimez les super héros xii
et moi un super-héros deux minutes cinq
ans d en fait non mais non mais
qu'est-ce que je me fous tout ça donc je
crois que tu aimes le foot roux hall 2a
et coffrets coffret collector non 75 ans
de la voiture marvel atteint les brodard
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que j'ai fait des séances d'uv
alors benhaim et je tiens à teaneck
avait déjà offert un cadeau oui mais on
s'en fout c'est un deuxième cadeau scam
a ouvert allons faire une bague dans ma
loge la dernière fois c'était fait
exprès alors par contre j'adore mais
elles sont les pistes
une odeur genre livre c'est le sexe pour
les nuls donc voilà ça apporte ses pieds
une over les pieds puis malenfant
alors c'est un taux qui est un peu
exceptionnel c'est mon premier tour de
magie c'est là bas ça sera certainement
le dernier aussi je voulais vous l'avez
fait dans le truc là je me suis entraîné
à deux trois ou alors tient à passer au
bois parce que je vous ai fait une
peinture avec trois choses que j'adore
[Rires]
alors c'est pas tout ça mais alors que
les trois choses qu'il aime c'est quoi
fatou oui une margarita et mon nez et ça
fait quoi ça d'abord saison pour les
schistes se croirait tout va être fait
le point elle le connaît par coeur à
lapins poules pondeuses je viens des
jolies femmes tu as un long couteau
tués'' et une fine lame vous êtes
gratton chez tailler dans le vif tout
est frais rouvière qu'aujourd'hui tu as
dans le vif
mais moi que mon cadeau te plaise août
un support c'est avec tout mon coeur que
là je te la porte
regardez ce qu'elle m'a offert
elle m'a offert 10 mai allemand faire
elle m'a offert des couteaux tu m'as
pris pour nabil
sinon c'est avec ça qu'on l'a circoncis
montiel alors alors à part les séances
d'uv
ah mais oui mais à leurs fins et kadia
ton pote de mon ami un truc sinon c'est
moi qui laissait le porte clés de ma
maison du pilat voilà que je voudrais
chap à munich les deux noms connard me
donne aux portes auxquelles je vais
rester devant la maison c'est pas la
maison je vous donne c'est le porte-clés
c'est déjà pas mal de la maison tu la
gagnes en faisant trois trucs sur vidéo
gag sur le projet
[Musique]